- Thanks to ExpressVPN for keeping
Legal Eagle safe and in the air.
Despite the dire situation
that the world is experiencing
because of the COVID-19 pandemic,
some people just have to be jerks,
like this guy, Larz, a
California, quote, "influencer"
who thought it would be
cute to lick a toilet
and dub it the coronavirus challenge.
- Coronavirus challenge!
- He later ended up in the
hospital with coronavirus.
Larz inspired people like Ava Louise
to lick a toilet seat herself,
and this other guy, Cody Lee Pfister,
filmed himself licking a
row of deodorant at Walmart.
- Who's scared of coronavirus?
Don't touch your mouth.
- Pfister was arrested,
or this group of Cincinnati
residents who flouted
the governor's social distancing orders
by throwing a coronavirus party.
The legal term for these people is idiots,
and what do all of these
idiots have in common,
besides being nominees for
the 2020 Darwin Awards?
They may have done
things that could result
in lawsuits or even jail time.
(dramatic music)
Hey legal eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because today we're gonna talk about
a bunch of different cases where people
intentionally or knowingly expose others
to the novel coronavirus.
What happens when someone pulls a prank
and coughs on the salad bar?
Is it a criminal offense
to give someone COVID-19?
And what happens if you
intentionally try to infect others?
I'm here to answer all of these questions
and scare you away from ever
eating at a restaurant again.
Now, let's start with the
basics of assault and battery.
Most causes of action
for spreading COVID-19
would probably be on the state level
starting with assault and battery,
which are both tort claims
and criminal offenses.
The same conduct can lead
to a personal injury lawsuit
and a criminal prosecution,
depending on who initiates
the case and the severity of the actions
that we're talking about here.
Battery is generally defined
as a harmful or offensive
contact with another person's body.
Now, the victim's body
under this definition
is usually extended to include things
that the victim is attached to.
This is called the
extended personality rule.
This means grabbing someone's shirt
or yanking their necklace
or spitting in their cup
can also be battery,
even if the perpetrator
never actually touches the victim's body.
Now, purposefully spreading
a disease to another person
generally fits within the definition
of a harmful or offensive touching.
It's certainly not
something that people want
in their everyday lives.
For example, in
Pennsylvania a malicious man
in a grocery store was arrested
after deliberately coughing
in the face of an older
gentleman wearing a face mask
and gloves because of the
potential fatal risk of COVID-19.
This jerk, or idiot, as we
say in the legal profession,
allegedly coughed and mocked the man
and told him that he was
now infected with the virus.
This guy was also charged with
making terroristic threats
as well as battery, and we'll talk about
the terrorism charges in just a second.
Now, similarly, assault is
usually lumped in with battery,
but it's technically a separate offense.
It's usually the intentional
act that causes another person
to fear that they're about
to suffer physical harm.
If a person is placed in
imminent fear of bodily harm,
this is punishable as a crime
or again as a tort as well.
Imagine you're playing
pool with someone in a bar
and that person gets angry and
swings their pool cue at you.
In most places in America,
if they make contact,
it's battery, but if they swing
and miss, that is assault,
and you guessed it, this can apply
to spreading COVID-19 as well.
For example, in Maryland a
man named William Eddings
was charged with second degree assault
and four counts of
exposure by an individual
who has an infectious disease
in violation of state law
after he got in an altercation
with one of his father's tenants,
screaming and chasing
the man into his vehicle,
where Eddings spit on his arm twice.
When police arrived, Eddings
said he had tested positive
for COVID-19 and then
spat at the officers.
Again, not a smart guy here.
Now, under Maryland law,
assault is defined as an attempt
to make an offensive contact with another
or intentionally
frightening another person.
Eddings' saliva actually
hit the victim's arm,
which is definitely a battery,
and although his spit didn't
make contact with the officers,
spitting in their direction
is a clear attempt
to scare them and that was
enough for the assault charge.
And in this generation
where we're worried about
droplets of water in the air,
it could be argued that
even if the main spit,
and it's ridiculous that I have to go down
to this fact situation,
but even if the main wad
didn't make contact, even
the droplets in the air
might qualify as a battery itself.
And since assault and
battery are also torts,
it's conceivable that someone
like Eddings could be sued
for assault and battery in state court
and pay civil damages to the victims here.
And Maryland, like many other states,
have specific statutes that actually deal
with the intentional spreading
of infectious diseases,
and that's one of the things
that this guy was charged with.
But I mentioned terroristic threats,
and these days most states
have a criminal offense
called terroristic threats,
and this offense is probably not the thing
you're thinking of when you
hear the word terrorist.
It has nothing to do
with foreign governments
or international elements.
This is generally a
verbal or written threat
to commit an act meant to
terrorize another party.
When you do that, you can get
arrested, not surprisingly.
The threat can be paired
with an actual crime,
like battery or murder, but it
can also be a general threat
meant to terrorize.
So for example, if you
called up your high school
and made a bomb threat, for instance,
if there was no specific statute
dealing with bomb threats,
you'd probably be charged with
making terroristic threats,
even if no one was in
actual physical apprehension
of physical contact, which
would be required for assault.
Unfortunately, there are
many examples of people
doing really stupid and dangerous things
during this pandemic
that probably give rise
to a crime of terroristic threats.
For example, a New Jersey
man was arrested for coughing
on a Wegmans employee,
and telling the woman that
he had the coronavirus.
The employee said that
she was concerned that
he was standing too
close to the salad bar,
and she asked him to move.
He then coughed on her and laughed,
and claimed that he had the virus.
He was charged with making
a terroristic threat.
He was also charged with
obstruction and harassment.
A Texas teenager posted
several videos claiming that
she had the COVID-19 infection,
and wanted to kill people with it.
- If you wanna get the coronavirus,
woo that, call me.
And I will meet you up, and
(coughs) all up (coughs)
all over you.
- Obviously, the police were concerned,
and they tracked her down.
Now, this is not without controversy.
The terrorism laws were intended to apply
to terroristic acts to a group of people,
and generally were not meant to apply
to a single individual person
talking to another person.
But generally, true threats
are not considered free speech
and not protected by the First Amendment,
though it's still
controversial as to whether
these statements constitute
a true threat or not,
so it sort of begs the question,
which I'm actually using
the correct way this time.
But there is precedent for
using state terroristic threats
to prosecute people for exposing others
to infectious diseases.
Prosecutors charged
individuals with making
terroristic threats for
exposing their sexual partners
to HIV in the 1990s
which led to new statutes
specifically directed
towards infectious diseases.
According to the Center
for HIV Law and Policy,
roughly 2/3 of states have
laws that make it a crime
to knowingly expose others to HIV,
among other infectious diseases.
For example, in April
2012, a 19-year-old man
who had HIV was charged with assault
and battery with a deadly
weapon, among other things,
for failing to disclose his HIV status
to multiple sexual partners.
At least one of his partners
later tested positive for HIV.
At least 12 states have
added hepatitis C to the list
of diseases that could
cause criminal prosecution
if the infected person
knowingly exposes other people,
though public health
advocates believe legislators
should be cautious about passing more laws
criminalizing the spread of disease,
because it can also stigmatize
testing and treatment.
There are probably fewer
issues with adding COVID-19
to the list of diseases that are covered
by these disclosure laws,
since COVID-19 is easier
to transmit than hepatitis C or HIV,
and COVID-19 arguably gives
prosecutors a better argument
for aggressively charging
people who threaten to expose
others to the virus because
of its ease of communication.
Now, the state of mind
here is always important.
Almost all criminal laws have
a mental state requirement
or mens rea, or guilty mind, component.
You can't be criminally prosecuted
just because you accidentally
infected someone.
You have to intentionally
or knowingly infect them
in situations that give rise to liability.
So don't think that anyone who happens
to communicate the disease is going
to be prosecuted under these laws.
But where there is
really egregious conduct,
the prosecutors are probably
gonna bring out the big guns.
- Time to bring out the big guns.
- And one of the most egregious examples
of intentionally exposing
people to COVID-19
happened when Margaret
Cirko went to a supermarket
and started coughing and
spitting on the food.
Cirko claimed to have the coronavirus,
and coughed or spit on
about $35,000 worth of food,
which had to be thrown out.
Authorities don't yet know
if Cirko really had COVID-19,
but her actions caused
serious losses to the store,
in addition to potentially
exposing employees
and shoppers to the virus.
She was arrested and charged
with two felony counts
of terroristic threats,
one felony count of threats
to use a biological agent,
and one felony count
of criminal mischief.
It's worth noting that it
probably doesn't matter
if she actually has the virus or not.
For example, if you fire
an unloaded gun at someone,
but you think that gun is loaded,
that still generally
qualifies as attempted murder.
Now, Cirko being cited
for threatening to spread
a biological agent brings us to whether
federal anti-terrorism laws
could apply to COVID-19.
And on March 24th, Deputy
Attorney General Jeffrey Rosen
sent U.S. attorneys and federal
law enforcement agencies
a memo recommending that
people who purposefully expose
or infect others with
COVID-19 should be prosecuted
under federal terrorism statutes.
Now, there are several federal statutes
that the DOJ is considering.
The first is 18 U.S.C. 2332 which makes it
a federal offense to
threaten or attempt to use
a weapon of mass
destruction against persons
within the United States, and
a weapon of mass destruction
is any weapon involving
a biological agent,
toxin, or a vector, and
biological agents are defined
to include viruses
capable of causing death,
disease, or other biological
malfunction in a human.
Now, a defense attorney
would probably argue that
the statute was intended to apply
to artificially created vectors,
and not the naturally occurring
cold viruses or coronaviruses.
But the statute is written
broadly enough to apply,
and despite rumor-mongering
to the contrary,
there is no evidence that
COVID-19 was engineered
by China as a biological weapon,
but the statute probably still
brings it under its aegis.
Now, Rosen did not mention 18 U.S.C. 1365,
which penalizes tampering
with consumer products,
even though it arguably
applies to people like Cirko
who go around tampering
with consumer products.
However, this law was used
to arrest the mastermind
of the biggest bioterrorism
attack in U.S. history,
and could be useful in stopping people
from spreading COVID-19.
Now, this example is so crazy
it probably bears mentioning.
In the early 1980s, Bhagwan
Rajneesh, also known as Osho,
amassed a number of devoted
religious followers in India,
moved to the United States,
took over an Oregon town,
fought with a co-founder of Nike,
acquired the largest
collection of Rolls-Royces
in the world, violated immigration laws,
sedated thousands of homeless people,
tried to assassinate public officials,
and infected 751 people with salmonella
by contaminating eight
restaurant salad bars.
The salad bar poisoning
was a plan to stop people
from voting in a local election,
and if you've ever seen
the Netflix documentary
"Wild, Wild Country"
you've no doubt witnessed
Osho's right-hand man, Ma Anand Sheela,
memorably justifying the cult's actions.
- What can I say, tough titties.
- The Rajneeshees stole
the salmonella cultures
from a Seattle lab, and Sheela
pleaded guilty to conspiring
to tamper with consumer
products and wiretapping.
Federal law makes it a
crime to tamper with food
by exposing it to toxic
chemicals or bacteria or viruses,
as the Rajneeshees did in
Oregon, not surprisingly,
and also there are a bunch
of state laws that prohibit
tampering with food products as well.
Remember this girl who
looked a tub of ice cream,
and then put it back?
Well, she was arrested with
tampering with food products
under a Texas tampering law,
and this kind of tampering has been
on the federal radar since February,
when an FBI briefing disclosed
that white supremacists
have discussed using
COVID-19 as a bioweapon,
including leaving saliva on door handles,
spitting on elevator buttons,
and using some of the same
tactics as the Rajneeshees.
Now, that's a summary of
the sort of criminal acts
that you might be charged
with if you go around
intentionally infecting
other people with COVID-19,
but what about just walking around,
or defying a lockdown order?
Well, I have a video all about
the government's legal
authority to isolate
and quarantine people
during a health crisis,
and in that video I
talked about the history
of quarantine laws, Typhoid
Mary, and the Spanish flu,
and the other stuff that
happens during a pandemic,
and my conclusion was
that lawsuits challenging
COVID-19 quarantines and
restrictions on public gatherings
would probably fail because
the police power of the states
are really at their zenith
in situations like this.
But what about the liability
of people who break
those quarantine and isolation orders?
Well, we've now witnessed
state authorities using
their broad powers to
issue orders requiring
businesses to close,
people to remain at home,
and sick patients to be
isolated and quarantined.
But the unique nature of
this crisis has governors,
mayors, and police making ad hoc decisions
about the quarantine, and apart
from the criminal liability
and potential jail time
of defying these orders,
you might also be on the hook for damages
caused by just people getting
sick from your actions,
and I think there are
a couple avenues here.
One is what's called negligence per se.
Negligence per se is the
law's way of imposing
strict liability on
specific circumstances.
Strict liability is automatic liability.
So this means that the
defendant is liable,
regardless of the defendant's intent
or what they knew or what
they should have known.
If strict liability applies,
the defendant has to pay
for his or her conduct if it
caused the plaintiff's injuries
and one of the ways to
trigger negligence per se is
when you break the law.
If you break the law or
there is a statute that says
you cannot conduct
these particular actions
and you go and do that,
the law sometimes says that
you have to pay for the
damage that you cause,
regardless of whether you
acted negligently or not.
So for example, in Connecticut
a woman was injured
after a dog that was subject
to a 14 day quarantine escaped.
The woman sued the local dog warden,
and on appeal the court
of appeals held that
the dog warden could be sued
and immunity did not apply
because the dog catcher
violated the quarantine law,
and in a somewhat analogous situation
a Minnesota couple sued a
physician they hired to take care
of their daughter who had scarlet fever.
The physician allowed
the parents to visit her
and take her home when her disease
was at its most contagious,
advising them that
she wasn't really contagious.
The Minnesota Supreme
Court found that the doctor
could be sued for negligence.
So this is a fluid situation.
You can probably expect
many negligence lawsuits
against healthcare
facilities, cruise ships,
and other businesses if the
plaintiff can prove that
any of these entities
failed to take precautions
or violated some law that
allowed them to be infected,
and the same may be true for employees
in high-risk professions or locations
who are recklessly exposed
the virus by their employers.
And if there's one takeaway here,
and I probably shouldn't
have to tell you this,
but I'm going to tell it to you anyway,
you shouldn't lick toilet seats.
You shouldn't lick food products.
And you shouldn't
intentionally spread COVID-19,
or you might face legal
liability, dummies.
And getting infected
with a virus is terrible,
whether we're talking about
a person or a computer,
because surfing the web
unprotected is almost as dumb,
which is why I'd recommend ExpressVPN.
For those of you who don't know,
a VPN basically creates a secure tunnel
from whatever device you're
using and the internet,
keeping your digital privacy intact,
and it's a big issue because
every time you connect
to an unencrypted Wi-Fi
network at airports,
hotels, coffee shops, remember all those?
Weren't those great?
Those were really, those
were, those were good.
Or even at home, you're at risk.
ExpressVPN encrypts your
internet connections
using the highest standards of encryption
currently available and
one of the privacy issues
in the U.S. is that ISPs often track
and sell your browsing
habits to advertisers.
And in my experience, ExpressVPN is also
the fastest VPN by far,
and one of the best parts
of ExpressVPN is you can
also reroute your connection
to a server in a country of your choice,
giving you unrestricted access
to parts of the internet
and making geo restrictions
a thing of the past.
Take watching Netflix, for example.
Say I wanna watch my
favorite British sci-fi show
about a time-traveling
alien doctor, I'm a fan,
but the selection with me
being in the United States
isn't like that if I was in the UK.
So once I switch my VPN,
I can pretty much watch
whatever I want, whenever I want.
Or maybe I wanna see what's trending
on YouTube in Belgium, or Japan.
Apparently, I'm huge in Japan,
and they also have 24/7 customer support,
which means your
questions will be answered
in seconds, not hours.
So if you wanna check
it out just head over
to expressvpn.com/legaleagle right now
and find out how you can
get three months free.
Again, that's ExpressVPN /legaleagle,
or just click on the
link in the description.
Clicking on that link really
helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other analysis about
the legal issues raised by COVID-19,
and just click on this playlist,
and I'll see you in court.